هرمونات الام تتغير كثيرا اثناء الحمل
وبعده لكن هناك ادله على ان الاباء يعانون
ايضا من تغيرات حقيقيه في مستويات
هرموناتهم بعد ولاده الطفل كما تلعب
الكثير من العوامل غير الهرمونيه دورها
ايضا في اصابه الاب باكتئاب ما بعد
الولاده منها اهمال الام لزوجها وتركيز
اهتمامها مع الطفل ما يجعل الاباء يوصابون
بالاكتئاب احيانا الضغط النفسي بسبب مهام
الابوه الجديده على الرجل تجعل توتره
وخوفه يزداد حول الشؤون الماليه والمهنيه
قله النوم فمعظم الاباء والامهات الجدد
يحصلون على عدد ساعات اقل من النوم وهذا
يمكن ان يكون له تاثير على المزاج ومن
العلامات الاكثر شيوعا لاصابه الرجال
بالاكتئاب الغضب وفقد الاهتمام بالعمل
والانشطه المفضله والانسحاب من العائله
والاصدقاء ونحن سالنا الناس في الاردن
ومصر برايك لماذا قد يصاب الرجل باكتئاب
ما بعد الولاده نتابع الاجابات
بعد ما يجون مولود تختلف حياته بصير عنده
زي مسؤوليه بصير يهتم بده يودي الدكتور
بده يعالجه بصحى له بالليل بزعجه هذا ايش
الواحد بيتعود عليه شوي شوي بصير اي شيء
عادي طبيعه لبين ما يكبر الولد ويصير يعني
اموره تمام خلص ساعتها برتاح وبتطمن عليه
انه يصير عنده مسؤوليه بده يربيه بده
يطلعه احسن ترباي بده يعلمه الصح من الغلط
بده يدرسه بده يطالعه منيح بالمجتمع ومش
اكتئاب هو كانه عايش بحيره انه صار في
عنده بيبي جديد عنده مسؤوليه كبيره يعني
بتفاجا وهي كلها راس مالها يعني اسبوعين
لاربعين يوم بتاقلم مع الجو واحد بيجي
مولود
بتغيب عليه كل شيء يعني لما بكون عزابي
لما بتجوز بيجي ولد
بتلاقيه يعني
حبابه بتعب الولد بضل يعيط بالليل يعني
الواحد بعرف شو عم بتغيب عليه روتين
بمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات